[Music]
feeling tired
bored powerless not anymore
experience all of command's core 16 new
flavors and
mix it up
uh
[Music]
hey v thanks for showing
talking with michael is like a game of
3d chess
don't let her derail you
i'm ready let's go
hold on i'll open it
lock like that no way you cracked it
open on your first try
you know how to get around those systems
appear so
i was hoping they hadn't run any updates
since i left
looks like i was right easy as pie yeah
follow me
judy alvarez i'd say it's great to see
you but i've never been one to lie
also i never like surprise parties but
you know
yep but i even know why thought you'd
hit rock bottom when you joined the mock
yes you've managed to stoop even lower
now
consorting with a common thug
yes v i mean you
don't mind me just here to blend into
the decor
that's no reason why come at all
to make sure judy gets what she came for
jude would have had a better chance
without you
judy has a proposal about clouds
wanna come back done always valued your
skills you know that
just don't get why you had to drag this
loose end in here
stop treating dolls like meat and i'll
consider it
but first things first clouds needs to
be taken from the tiger claws
okay look it's clear what happened to ev
was
[Music]
traumatic huh i was convinced you didn't
know
that girl was asking for an unhappy
ending
i was just surprised it took so long we
gotta do something
or everyone will end up like evie
woodman
raped her while she was unconscious then
sold her like she was so much scrapped
yeesh you've always been unstable
okay since you seem more reasonable care
to explain what this is about
you aware what woodman did to evelyn
when she was desperate for help
you sit by let that happen
tiger claw bosses rule this place know
how much i mean to them
about as much as you two and your
problems mean to me
read negligible
doesn't make you wonder why you even
work here gonna pretend as if you two
weren't ever here
for old time's sake judy literally
moments from now security's gonna figure
out you're here
got two options go out the way you came
in or get thrown out
and that's not a threat or figure of
speech just a friendly heads up
had enough i'm leaving
smart move and so you don't think i'm
brushing you off completely
forrest will be on the maintenance level
in a couple minutes
you picked the wrong side michael i'll
be the judge of that
i'm not your enemy here and i didn't ask
for your opinion
[Music]
that went smoothly she totally blew us
off
you know what i think she scared stiff
she'd have lots to lose if things went
sour
everything in fact so she'll just let
things go on as usual
ugh
you two have a history way back yeah
i think i just felt lonely like everyone
in night city
she was different then so was i
can't trust people that see everything
as a numbers game
line between patent you on the back is
their friend and playing a knifing you
as their enemy
is down to a decimal i know right there
with you
i well used to have a big crush on her
it took me a long time to realize what
she really was
but still honest or crooked we need her
just think could have gone diving this
morning a little unwind and do you good
do me good too actually i wouldn't have
been unwinding
not exactly got an idea buzzing in my
head
working it but i can't say if it'll
amount to anything
yeah you a deck chair and a mai tai with
a cocktail umbrella
somehow i don't see it no me and the
deck chairs me mulling over cuda [ __ ] of
what is
something i avoid right now
don't have an ounce of sympathy for that
[ __ ]
we go in there damn straight let's end
them
we'll take the elevator quickest way
created
several of her maintenance over the
years her first novel
i know it's worse than a corporal i
wanna be
corporal [ __ ] continuously you mean
michael
pisa work that one but i'll give her
credit
and is already considered a masterpiece
of post-collapse literature
this has been your world report thank
you for tuning in to n54 news
why don't you [ __ ] call me here
when evelyn needed help you raped her
could have also broken her neck hung up
her head like a chandelier
instead i took her to a ripper
just do a little something in return she
should be grateful
and so should you
here's my token of gratitude
[Music]
let's see let's get out of here
[Music]
[Music]
hmm
so
ugh
[Music]
hmm
almost felt like the world would be
revenge isn't everywhere people want to
believe it'll be the
miracle pill for their grief
that's not how it works
is
gotta get back to michael with something
big appealing to her sense of justice
wasn't big enough
michael only works with specifics
so what
gotta now we need more bodies that's for
sure
i'm gonna talk to the dolls
i'll call you when i've got something
see you later v
and thanks